bonjour à
tous
donc un petit point d'agenda comme nous
le faisons traditionnellement d'abord
pour vous dire mais vous le savez que
Nicolas Sarkozi est jusqu'à demain donc
en déplacement au
Maroc que demain justement mardi 23 juin
nous aurons à 18h notre traditionnel
bureau politique et qu'à 18h30 il y aura
un débat de
l'alternance animé par Jérémy Redler ici
dans dans la salle à côté au rchaussée
qui est délégué national aux fédérations
professionnelles et le thème qui sera
abordé c'est comment convaincre les
jeunes de s'engager en
politique alors mercredi à midi un point
presse est organisé avec Valérie pcrè et
l'ensemble des têtes de liste au
régional c'est donc un point presse où
présenteront l'ardoise des régions
socialistes donc à midi mercredi à 17h
la commission exécutive au siège des
républicains et ensuite à 18h30 débat de
l'alternance avec Madeleine Bazin de GC
sur le thème comment remettre la
transmission au cœur de nos écoles jeudi
après-midi Nicolas Sarkozi participera
au sommet du PPE au Parlement européen à
Bruxelles un petit point sur les
élections municipales partielles
dont le deuxème tour avait lieu hier
dimanche après la belle
victoire la semaine dernière dès le
premier tour à puto les républicains ont
confirmé dans la plupart des
ville à noté la victoire et la conquête
de la ville de clichi
lagaren qui passe à droite pour la
première fois depuis
1925 euh c'est à noter et euh avec une
belle victoire du républicain Rémi Musau
avec
57,8 % des voix
euh et également une victoire celle-là
euh euh plus annoncée puisque c'est
Manuel haschlimag qui a été réélu mère
dannière avec
56,3 % des voix et donc euh on peut
s'apercevoir que euh désormais les
hautes scènes n'ont plus un seul maire
plus aucune ville dirigée par un maire
socialiste et donc nos amis de des
hautes scènes ont ouvert les yeux ont vu
que la gestion socialiste de leur
commune était une catastrophe et donc
ils ont fait le choix des républicains
euh à chaque fois
euh une autre élection partielle la
deuxème ville euh demiselle avec Anne
gromerch qui a été réélu à Thionville
avec
53,7 % des voies c'est une belle
confirmation de la part d'Anne
grommerche alors juste pour ajouter sur
les municipales dans ce département qui
est l'un des départements les plus
dynamiques de France on voit que les
électeurs ont choisi euh de donner et de
confier la gestion de ces villes euh aux
républicains en balayant les socialistes
et on voit une fois encore que la
stratégie du président Nicolas Sarkozi a
porter ses fruits le rassemblement
permet de conquérir des villes et nous
noterons qu'il a fait deux déplacements
deux meetings dans dans le département
des Hautes scènes donc son
investissement permet également d'avoir
des résultats à la hauteur de nos
espérances et nous poursuivrons cette
stratégie de rassemblement pour que
l'alternance ait lieu en
2017 alors on va oui on va passer au aux
socialistes euh avec cette tout d'abord
pour commenter cette matinale de Camba
d'élice où il a évoqué dans des termes
légèrement xénophobe pour reprendre ses
propres propos euh Christiane tobira en
disant qu'elle donnait de la couleur euh
au gouvernement donc nous trouvons ça
absolument inadmissible de parler de de
la couleur d'une d'une femme
politique donc voilà encore une fois
Monsieur
kambadellis démontre à quel point il est
légèrement xénophobe voire raciste ses
déclarations sont absolument douteuses
autre point douteux la nomination de
Yassine schwat comme secrétaire national
du Parti socialiste à l'intégration
monsieur schouat a été condamné pour
violence conjugale euh monsieur
cambaéiss à mon sens a minimisé l'ffit
ce matin encore chez euh Bruce toussin
il y a un silence également
assourdissant euh de la part de Pascal
Boitard de Marisol Touren de Najad
valallobelkassem qui était quand même
ministre des Droits des Femmes il y a eu
aucune réaction suite à la nomination de
de de cette de cette personne donc euh
voilà nous sommes un peu stupéfaits de
cette nomination stupéfait de la
légèreté avec laquelle a été euh euh
faite cette nomination c'est absolument
irresponsable c'est un message
dramatique envoyé aux femmes victimes de
violence conjugal euh puis on peut se on
a quelques doutes également sur le
secrétariat national qui a été confié à
Monsieur schwat l'intégration dans le
pôle République euh et puis euh bien sûr
la victimisation euh de monsieur chwat
qui euh qui dit que être musulman en
France et bien on n pas on n' pas le
droit à une seconde chance euh nous
considérons que monsieur schouat est un
citoyen français il a été un élu et à
aucun moment nous nous devons mettre nos
religion nos origines pour en avant pour
justifier certains faits donc il y a une
instrumentalisation de la confession de
Monsieur Chouat pour pour essayer de
rattraper des faits qui sont des faits
qui l'accablent et puis une condamnation
qui ne peut
que que une condamnation qui ne peut que
que que que rendre inadmissible cette
cette nomination en tant que que
secrétaire
national ce weekend madame tobira a
particulièrement trépigné vous l'avez vu
dans les différents médias où elle a pu
s'exprimer d'abord elle a
trépigné sur le temps de travail euh en
révant de ne travailler que 32 he donc
nous nous avons fait un rêve c'est que
Madame tobira ne travaille plus au
ministère de la Justice du
tout Z0 he je pense que c'est le temps
de travail qu'il faudrait qu'elle
effectue au ministère de la Justice pour
le bien-être des Français et surtout
pour à la fois la sérénité de la justice
et pour
que la justice fasse son travail avec
plein et entier avec donc toute la
rigueur nécessaire pour combattre la
délinquence pour faire en sorte
que ceux de nos concitoyens qui ne
respectent pas les règles et bien soient
sanctionné et
donc pour la paix sociale et
républicaine dans notre pays 32h pour
Madame tobira ce serait déjà beaucoup
trop ensuite madame tobira a décidé de
s'attaquer à la justice des mineurs euh
nous avions fait une réforme importante
pour notamment les mineur récidivist de
16 à 18 ans en mettant en place un
tribunal correctionnel pour mineurs
et Madame tobira a fait de son maintien
au gouvernement
euh a mis une condition à son maintien
au gouvernement pardon c'est-à-dire que
elle puisse revenir sur ce dispositif et
bien nous invitons le président de la
République et le Premier ministre à
tenir bon et ne pas lui donner
satisfaction parce que ce sera aussi un
moyen pour madame tobiera de quitter le
ministère de la Justice et donc de
cesser à faire tant de mal à notre
justice puisqu'elle est toujours sur la
même philosophie c'est supprimer les
incarcération euh
aujourd'hui avec le texte qui a été voté
je vous rappelle que pour les peenes qui
vont jusqu'à 5 ans et
bien on peut passer par la contrainte
pénale et donc que les délinquants
puissent ne pas faire un jour de prison
euh pour exemple jusqu'à 5 ans les
agressions sexuelles sont concernées et
donc euh pour agression sexuelle un
délinquamp peut euh éviter la case
prison la case incarcération et en 2017
c'est pour les peine allant jusqu'à 10
ans de prison que euh euh cette mesure
va se mettre en place je rappelle que
euh jusqu'à 10 ans de prison ce sont les
trafics d'armes les cambriolages les
attaques à main armées et bien toutes
euh tous ces
euh toutes ces infractions euh ne sont
plus forcément sanctionnables par une
incarcération
ensuite euh madame tobira euh app a
apparemment euh
quelques difficultés relationnelles on
va dire avec euh ses collaborateurs
puisque nous souhaitons aujourd'hui la
bienvenue à son 4e directeur de cabinet
en 3 ans euh il prend ses fonctions
aujourd'hui nous lui souhaitons euh bon
courage et puis surtout nous nous nous
lui souhaitons de rester un peu plus
longtemps que les autres et donc de
savoir faire preuve euh j'allais dire
euh d'une certaine persévérance euh en
tout cas si Madame tobirra euh demeure
encore quelques temps au ministère de la
Justice euh et nous nous demandions
euh quel était les réflexions sur ce
sujet des
syndicat de magistrat et notamment du
Syndicat de la magistrature puisque pour
la première fois le directeur de cabinet
du garde des saau ne sera pas issu de la
magistrature vous savez d'habitude c'est
un magistrat ou un conseiller d'État qui
exerce cette fonction euh là apparemment
pour supporter madame toubira il a a dû
être fait appel à un préfet en retraite
peut-être que de par son
parcours il a su faire preuve d'un d'une
certaine sérénité en toutes
circonstances et donc c'est peut-être ce
qui lui permettra euh de passer
apparemment tous les
orages au ministère de la
Justice puis la bourde de la semaine
donc c semaine le prix spécial revient à
Najat valob belcassem et et donc pour
pour les programmes dans lesquels il y a
une absence on voit que pour la
terminale elle est la première
scientifique il n'y a plus de
philosophie ni d'histoire
géographie c'est un oubli alors est-ce
que c'est de l'amateurisme ou un acte
manqué l'avenir nous le dira mais en
tout cas voilà nous lui remettons le
prix spécial de de la semaine
et puis peut-être un dernier petit
commentaire sur les 32 heur que souhaite
madame tobira c'est vrai que c'est le
vieux serpent de maire de la politique
notamment à gauche
diviser les heures de travail en
espérant créer de l'emploi on a vu avec
les 35 he que ça ne marche pas et
faut-il peut-être le rappeler travaill
32h c'est bien pour dégager un peu de
temps pour les loisirs mais est-ce que
les Français ont les moyens de se payer
des loisirs aujourd'hui j'en doute donc
je ne vois vraiment pas la la pertinence
de la proposition de de Madame
tobira